[Musique]
dans une autre vie elle a été une pro de
la com mais en politique ne comptez pas
sur elle pour faire des coups d'éclat
mon invité assume un style à la fois
sérieux et plutôt
[Musique]
discret bonjour mod Gatel bonjour alors
vous êtes aujourd'hui député MoDem de
Paris mais votre engagement politique il
a d'abord été marqué par l'Europe une
passion pour l'Europe qui remonte à loin
elle remonte à ça
expliquez-nous alors c'est l'album
Panini que ma maman m'a offert quand
j'étais très très jeune je pense que
j'avais 9 10 ans euh parce que j'ai
développé assez tôt une passion pour
pour l'Europe en construction euh je
pense en lien avec la chute du mur qui
m'avait beaucoup marqué d'accord
j'allais vous demander si vous avez
offert un un album de footballeur est-ce
que vous seriez devenu footballeuse mais
non ça a précédé la passion pour
l'Europe a précédé l'album absolument en
tout cas c'est comme ça que je je je me
souviens des choses et c'est vrai que
j'avais été très marqué par cette
réconciliation des peuples qui avait
chez moi eu beaucoup beaucoup d'écho et
et et de fil en aiguille c'est ce qui
vous a amené à vous intéresser à la
politique très jeune alors c'est
vraiment mon engagement l'engagement
européen c'est l'engagement qui qui
demeure j'avais un engagement pour
l'environnement aussi très très jeune
ouais je me passionnais déjà pour la
question des déchets et du recyclage et
donc finalement j'aiimé deux piliers
l'environnement et l'Europe et et et la
politique en général parce que je crois
que dès l'âge de de 9 ans vous êtes
passionné pour la pour la présidentielle
de de 1988 François mitteron face à
Jacques Chirac ça a continué pour vous
au collège au lycée sauf que vous
expliquez que la politique cétait en
quelque sorte pour vous un un spectacle
et que vous vous imaginiez pas pas
forcément monter sur scène pour être un
peu une actrice de ce spectacle pourquoi
ben je considérais que la politique
c'était pas pour moi c'était un intérêt
très fort effectivement je m'intéressais
beaucoup à l'actualité je me souviens
très bien de ces images mais je voyais
ça comme quelque chose d'extérieur à moi
où je n'étais qu'une spectatrice et
absolument pas une actrice pour vous
c'était une forme d'autocensure lié à je
sais pas à votre environnement social
c'était peut-être une autocensure et en
tout cas je je ne voyais pas le chemin
pour moi pour y prendre part alors vous
pensez que c'est c'est encore quelque
chose qui est qui est valable pour
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui cette
idée que bah la politique s'est réservée
à une certaine catégorie de la
population alors j'en suis convaincu et
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'autocensure effectivement y compris
aujourd'hui et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je travaille justement à ouvrir
la politique sur la
société pour
donner l'envie le goût mais surtout les
clés pour celles et ceux qui veulent
s'engager qui le sont déjà vous faites
quoi quoi concrètement pour ça c'est
c'est c'est un peu la politique hors les
murs c'est montrer que finalement il y a
différentes formes d'engagement qui à un
moment où un autre peuvent prendre aussi
une forme politique c'est pas à la place
c'est pas mais aussi une forme politique
et que ce milieu n'est pas fermé n'est
pas réservé à quelques-uns mais qu'il
est au contraire le plus ouvert possible
et je travaille vraiment à ce qu'il le
soit encore davantage alors vous avez
quand même fait les études dont vous
rêviez Science Po à
Bordeaux peu après vous avez décroché un
stage auprès de Michel Barnier à la
Commission européenne et ensuite
Marielle de sarnis vous a embauché comme
collaboratrice au Parlement européen
quel souvenir est-ce que vous gardez de
ces 7 années passées avec Marielle de
Sarnez alors d'abord je garde un d'abord
elle m'a beaucoup beaucoup appris la
rigueur le toujours le souci du détail
et puis je garde
aussi je je dis souvent que je suis un
un bébé du Parlement européen c'estàdire
j'ai été élevé à cette culture du
compromis du travail ensemble
de faire en sorte de travailler sur des
majorités autour de projets commun et
c'est vrai que parfois j'aspirerais à ce
que l'assemblée national s'inspire bien
davantage des pratiques du Parlement
européen pour revenir à Marielle de
sarnais c'était pas n'importe qui hein
dans la famille centrrice c'était
vice-présidente du MoDem longtemps bras
droit de de François Baayou vous vous
diriez qu'elle a été un peu votre mentor
en politique ou a totalement été mon
mentor oui et c'était une figure qui
était à la fois très respectée mais qui
avait aussi la réputation d'être assez
exigeante très
exigeante c'était parfois compliqué elle
savait absolument ce qu'elle voulait et
elle se elle donnait la même enfin elle
avait la même exigence pour les autres
qu'elle avait à l'égard d'elle-même et
effectivement le niveau était très élevé
mais je pense que quiconque l'a croisé
au cours au cours de sa de sa carrière
de femme politique lui reconnaît à la
fois cette excellence cette rigueur
cette exigence pour elle-même avant
d'être l'exigence pour les autres pour
les autres alors au bout de CT an à ses
côtés vous avez tourné la page à la fois
du Parlement européen et de Marielle de
Sarnez pour vous lancer dans une
carrière dans la communication d'abord
chez tilder puis chez TBWA qui sont un
peu des des références dans le secteur
vous donniez des conseils je crois à des
grands patrons ou à des dirigeant
d'organisme public on est très loin de
la politique et de ce que vous faisiez
avant pourquoi pourquoi ce choix-là vous
aviez envie de changer d'air c'était non
en fait la politique c'est la politique
qui m'a attrapé à un moment où je
m'attendais pas du tout à avoir cette
opportunité j'ai énormément appris et
apprécié C ces SEP années passées à côté
de Marielle de Sarnez mais j'ai toujours
voulu avoir un vrai métier euh pouvoir
c'està-dire gagner votre vie VI
indépendamment de la politique
absolument et par ailleurs je
considérais que c'était compliqué d'être
à la fois payé par la politique en tant
que salarié et élu et j'aspirais
effectivement à à me présenter à des
élections et j'ai toujours beaucoup
apprécié la communication et par
ailleurs je je pense qu'on peut faire
aussi de grandes choses avec les
organisations avec les entreprises et je
je pense avoir aussi servi l'intérêt
général à travers mon engagement auprès
de certains grands dirigeants
d'entreprise alors en parallèle de cette
carrière dans la com vous êtes resté
engagé en en politique mais c'était plus
au niveau européen vous êtes passé au
niveau local vous avez été élu
conseillère de Paris vous avez pris la
tête du MoDem à Paris j'ai même lu que
vous n'excluez pas de vous présenter
comme candidate à la mairie de Paris
plus tard j'aime infiniment cette ville
qui m'a adopté il a 25 ans maintenant et
je souffre beaucoup de voir se dégrader
notre patrimoine qu'il soit
architectural végétal et de voir que
chaque année il y a des des 12000
parisiens qui quittent la ville parce
qu'ils aspirent à autre chose et je
pense que on a besoin d'uneune grande
ambition pour Paris et je continuerai à
à porter cette ambition et je prendrai
toute ma part au changement que
j'appelle de mes vœux vous avez de
grandes ambitions politiques c'est c'est
tout à fait légitime vous occupez des
fonctions importantes au modem vous êtes
êt devenu secrétaire général de de ce
parti mais vous êtes très discrète dans
les médias et c'est vrai que pour une
pro de la com ça peut surprendre
pourquoi pourquoi cette discrétion alors
c'est pas une discrétion qui est voulue
c'est une discrétion
qui qui finalement est le fait de
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire et
d'un emploi du temps qui est très chargé
mais ça n'est pas ça n'est pas rev
réservez aucune place dans votre emploi
du temps au médias alors pas
suffisamment en tout cas et et je compte
bien et vous aime vous aimez pas ça
aller sur un plateau télé si j'aime bien
j'aime bien ça pour aller défendre des
convictions j'aime j'aime beaucoup
effectivement les sujets de fond j'aime
beaucoup pouvoir débattre sur des idées
et je devrais faire un petit peu plus de
place dans mon agenda au solliicitation
médiia alors Marielle de sarnais est
revenue dans votre vie en 2017 à
l'occasion des législatives elle vous a
proposé demander je sais pas de d'être
sa suppléante à l'occasion de ce scrutin
vous lui avez dit non deux fois puis à
la troisème vous avez dit oui mais
pourquoi lui avoir dit non de deux fois
pourquoi alors elle m'a proposé parce
que j'étais présidentE du MoDem Paris à
l'époque et j'avais été candidate sur
cette circonscription 5 ans
auparavant mais effectivement moi je je
j'aspirais à poursuivre ma carrière
professionnelle elle avait c'était à la
suite de l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron et
j'imaginais bien qu'elle prendrait de
grandes responsabilités et c'était pas
c'était pas pour moi le moment mais
Mariel on lui a résisté jamais très
longtemps et donc j'ai fini
effectivement par lui dire oui donc
Mariel de sarnaz est est décédée d'une
lecémie foudroyante en janvier 2021 il y
a eu évidemment le choc l'émotion et
puis très vite euh le moment du choix
pour vous qui étiz sa suppléante en
quelques jours bah vous avez dû décider
soit de siéger à l'Assemblée en tant que
député soit de rester dans la
communication où vous étiez promise à à
une carrière brillante ça a été un
moment un choix difficile à faire pour
vous ça a été un moment d'abord très
difficile parce que quand vous perdez
quelqu'un qui est aussi important pour
votre famille politique et pour pour
vous-même c'est très très difficile je
pense qu'il y a pas pire manière
d'entrer à l'Assemblée nationale que
d'entrer à l'Assemblée nationale la
suite du décès de la personne qui vous a
tout appris le choix a été compliqué
mais il s'est finalement assez
rapidement imposé dans la mesure où je
considérais que il y avait une suite à à
donner au parcours de Mariel et que mon
engagement politique pouvait aussi
prendre cette forme là vous l'avez dit
hein vous avez fait vos débuts à
l'Assemblée dans des conditions
particulières vent difficile lié avant
tout au décès de Marielle de sarnaz mais
mais c'est aussi cette idée que bah vous
avez dû monter dans un train en marche
sur une législature qui était engagée
depuis 3 ans comment ça se passe
concrètement quand on débarque comme ça
alors que tout le monde est déjà rodé en
quelque sorte 4 ans
même ben on essaie de se faire sa place
en en restant sur ses propres
fondamentaux et moi j'ai eu la chance
d'être merveilleusement bien accueilli
par par mon groupe et par Jean-Louis
bourlange le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères qui m'a confié
en fait un rapport qui avait été
souhaité par Marielle de sarnais sur
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Union
européenne qui est effectivement un un
un domaine de compétence et et une
passion pour moi et donc je me suis je
me suis j'ai fait ma place aussi avec un
un sujet que je connaissais bien et qui
m'intéressait particulièrement alors
depuis vous avez été réélu en faisant
campagne sur votre propre nom et et plus
en tant que suppléante euh vous menez
aujourd'hui de front trois engagements
différents hein député présidente du
groupe modem au Conseil de Paris et
secrétaire général du du MoDem vous qui
vouliez garder un un travail pour ne pas
vivre de la politique c'est un peu raté
là alors c'est un peu raté effectivement
euh c'est un peu raté mais c'est c'est
c'est le moment j'ai j'ai aussi j'ai
vraiment envie de de m'engager
complètement et quand j'essaie de faire
les choses je l' fait je l'ai fait à
fond ça demande effectivement une
organisation assez militaire pour faire
en sorte de de mener à bien ces trois
missions qui me tiennent toutes les
trois extrêmement à cœur allez on va on
va passer à notre quiz à présent euh
vous allez devoir compléter les les
phrases que je vais vous proposer vous
avez droit aujourd'hui à un quiz spécial
pro de la com voilà c'est comme ça vous
êtes prêtes c'est parti pour
déstabiliser Rashida Dati dans un débat
il
faut il faut
euh c'est pas si compliqué ah oui oui
vous l'avez vous l'avez fait elle a une
répartie extraordinaire et on peut la
déstabiliser mais
comment en en en rappelant des prises de
position passé de sa part en matière de
com tous les députés devraient prendre
exemple
sur alors sur la technique de com
malheureusement sur la France insoumise
sur la technique j'entends la forme pas
le F estimez qu'il y a une une
performance de leur part dans ce domaine
qui est ancienne qui remonte à
extrêmement longtemps mais la création
de toutes ces communautés qui datent de
aujourd'hui on voit leur présence sur
les réseaux sociaux effectivement le
travail mené depuis longtemps porte ses
fruits
aujourd'hui pour s'imposer en politique
mod Gatel devrait donc là c'est la
conseillère com face à mod Gatel donner
plus de temps dans son agenda aux médias
ah donc vous le reconnaissez j'ai une
dernière question avant de terminer je
m'adresse à nouveau à la pro de la com
quel conseil avez-vous donné à mod Gatel
avant de venir dans cette émission
euh d'essayer de répondre le plus le
plus de manière la plus courte possible
merci beaucoup mod Gatel d'être venu
dans la poli et
[Musique]
moi